I used to think people were wronging man
I'd get all angry and I'd spin myself
out I use a different frame now which is
they just wanted to feel better do you
think it had nothing to do with me and
they just wanted to feel better about
themselves being able to quiet the
hundreds of non-existent voices in my
head that were constantly judging the
activities that I was doing and labeling
them good or bad Etc took up a
tremendous amount of my attention
because of that all I was focused on was
feeling better in choosing not to admit
the deficiency between my current state
and the future state of what I desire to
be I was able to accept where I was and
then the deficiency of not being good
enough not being happy enough
disintegrated in my mind and then I was
able to focus on just doing things